okay I regularly receive videos of
interactions with police from people in
the audience usually I don't end up
talking about them on the show because
they don't see anything interesting or
the circumstances seem very blurry I
don't blurry or gray area maybe not
literally blurry video but just as
unclear exactly what's going on there's
nothing interesting I don't think
there's any interesting points to be
made but in the past there have been
some times that we successfully put a
spotlight on interactions between police
and citizens and a one example is back
in 2015 I received a video from Ohio of
a black man being pulled over for quote
making direct eye contact with a police
officer that clip ended up getting
nearly 300,000 YouTube views but more
importantly it actually led to a meeting
between the black man and the white
officer and I believe an apology and
maybe even further training for officers
it was a really great thing that was
able to come of it I have another video
for you today and another one of these
stories that I do want to talk about and
this one is from Fairfax County Virginia
and it involves a young black man back
in March the video was only recently
made available sitting in his car at a
red light driving home from work and
before I tell you the story make sure
that you subscribe like and share this
video if you're watching it on YouTube
we want this to be widely seen that's
how it will have the widest impact so
subscribe like the video and share it as
the story has been told to me an officer
Bush badge number four zero seven seven
started following the young black man
made eye contact as the officer passed
the black man the officer then makes a
u-turn in the middle of the street to
get right behind this young man and
follows the man into his neighborhood
and all the way to his apartment
building in fact at which point the
driver parks and the officer approaches
the man and starts asking questions that
don't seem quite right given the
circumstances including claiming not to
believe that the young black man
actually lives in the apartment complex
into which they've pulled despite the
fact that as I've been told the story
there is actually a resident parking
sticker on the driver side of the
vehicle driven by the young black man
that associates it with the apartment
complex in to which they pulled
so we have video and I want to show you
the video and there's a lot of
concerning things here let's look at
clip number one hey sir how you doing
how are you hey good hey do you live
here I do yes okay where do you live up
in this apartment right here okay yeah I
do
no no you have I do
I do have an ID okay do you have to show
it to you you don't have to is this your
car yes this okay is there a problem
what building do you live in this
building right here what's the address
I don't decide home tell you I don't
tell you to address what's that do I
need to tell you the address yeah what's
the address why don't you tell you my
address
I'm asking what the address is so I
don't need to tell you that because I'm
asking you but is there a reason why
you're asking me because I want to know
if you live here because if you don't
live here - totally I do live here great
but if you don't know the address so
notice that there's a series of
questions
none of which seemed to have any
relation to reasonable suspicion of a
crime having been committed the driver
knows his rights and is asserting them
and then it gets to the crux of what the
officer said there it doesn't look like
to me that you live here you don't look
like you live here what would be the
reason for that what about this man who
knows his rights and has done nothing to
warrant suspicion of a crime what about
his appearance suggests to the officer
that he doesn't really live in the
apartment complex in which he claims to
live now I know that there will be
people who will say David the driver is
being obstinate just give your ID state
the address and you'll be on your way
and this is exactly the problem this is
called phishing the officer asserts no
reason why he's following and now asking
repeated questions to this individual
the driver realizes that the officer is
phishing and he doesn't provide more
information and your reaction is that
the driver is the problem here by the
way again the driver reportedly has a
parking sticker for that parking complex
that apartment complex in a window on
the driver's side but again he doesn't
have to engage with this stuff if he
doesn't want to so
continue where he goes back to the car
questions about the car and questions
about how long the individual has lived
in the area Katherine whines now sweetie
why is that whose vehicle is this this
is my vehicle is it in your name and so
my mom's name is in my name also okay
how long have you lived in this area I'd
have to tell you that I'm just asking
you a question okay but why are you
asking me these questions
so you look here announcer I already
told you I do live here okay because if
you don't live here you're trespassing I
know that and I told you I live here
okay so what's the address that you live
at why do I have to tell you that
because I don't believe you live here
sir and why don't you believe me
why don't you believe I live because you
don't know the address Ari - I do know
the address okay what's the address that
you live I don't have to tell you that I
live here why you harassing me okay
I'm not harassing you yeah you're in my
neighborhood coming up to me tell me ask
me what my address is because you say I
don't live here why don't you believe I
love you if you don't live here then
you're trespassing do you have reason to
believe that I'm trespassing I mean
again other than the fact that you said
I don't look like I'd live here the
driver doesn't have to do the police
officers job for him and good for the
driver for saying you're telling me you
don't believe I live here but why are
you even talking to me right now these
questions or questions meant to try to
trip up or create an apparent
contradiction or even just to further
make the driver nervous as the driver
understandably is as you can hear in his
voice so that he then does something
justifying further interaction with the
officer whether it's searching the car
pulling the driver out whatever and the
driver you hear the nervousness in his
voice but he doesn't take the bait and I
think that's good now this is a good
point for me to make now this is not
about messing with police okay this is
about police messing with drivers who
have done nothing wrong that police can
articulate that would create suspicion
of any kind that a crime may have been
committed by this person I am NOT one of
these folks you see these videos on
YouTube where I'm about seeking out
Border Patrol checkpoints to refuse to
provide ID or answer questions to make
interesting YouTube videos I'm not about
that I think that that's generally a
waste of time
I'm not into driving deliberately into
sobriety checkpoints and trying to
interfere with the checkpoint whatever
right that that's not that's not why I
personally find that to be a waste of
time that's different here that's not
what's going on this is an individual
who is just driving home when this
officer decided this is someone that I'm
going to talk to and start asking
repeated harassing questions often you
will hear well the driver generally
matched the
description of someone we were looking
for police will say that that wasn't
said here and it hasn't been asserted
after the fact even though an
investigation has been opened up let's
now watch the end of the interaction sir
I'm not harassing you I don't have any
bass number you can detective Bush and
my badge number is four zero seven seven
okay thank you so do you have an ID on
you or not I do I already told you I do
have an ID okay what's your name I don't
have to tell you that am i being insane
am I free to go you're free to go sir
thank you have a good day ultimately
getting to the key question am I being
detained or am I free to go detective
Bush ultimately realizes he has no
business trying to detain this person he
has no justification for obtaining this
individual and the right question was
ultimately asked am I free to go and the
answer was yes this is a guy driving
around an officer decides that absent
any evidence or reason for suspicion
he's gonna mess with this guy and see
what he can find
he's going fishing let me throw my
fishing line in the water and see if
there's fish because why not maybe I'll
catch something and it gets worse
because the officer stayed at the
apartment complex just watching this guy
for a while a half-hour one additional
video just 8 seconds to show you
and there's the officer continuing to
wait around in the parking lot I don't
know more about this right now okay you
now have all the information that I have
I was sent this I watched all of these
videos multiple times in detail let's
see what comes comes of this I'm told
that internal affairs is now
investigating this knowing and asserting
your rights when you were being
confronted by police for no reason is
not being obstinate and this guy did the
right thing a lot of people don't know
what their rights are in these
situations
despite being clearly nervous you hear
the agitation in the black man's voice
and I understand it he asserted his
rights he remained calm and it doesn't
always go this way there are times when
merely asserting your rights in the way
that this individual did can actually
get you pulled out of the car and can
get the vehicle searched and there is a
risk associated with this approach we'll
see what comes of it this is a police
department that whose demographics are
drastically out of line with the
demographics of the community which they
police and this is an issue that's a
much broader issue in the United States
that we've talked about before Pete
Budaj actually brought this up at the
recent Democratic presidential debate so
let me know what you think about this as
as soon as I have more information I
will give it to you because this is all
I have so far please remember to
subscribe like and share this video we
do want as many people to see it as
possible we'll take a quick break make
sure you're following the show on
instagram at david pakman show follow me
on Instagram at David Pakman as well